the other ten thousand dollar bet i made
kind of recently and that was
self-driving cars at like a level five
running around uh cities and people have
kind of nitpicked that that we probably
don't mean exactly level five but the
guy i'm having the bet with i
is we're going to be we know what we
mean about this jeff atwood yeah coding
horror and
all yeah but i
yeah i mean it's just he doesn't think
that people are going to be riding
around in robo taxis in 2030 uh in major
cities just like like you take an uber
now and i think it will you think it
will and i think and the difference is
everybody looks at this it's like oh but
tesla's been wrong for you they've been
promising it for years and it's not here
yet and the reason this is different
than the bet with mars is mars
really is more than as comfortable a bet
on elon musk i am you know that is you
know that is his thing and he is really
going to move heaven and earth to try to
to make that happen and perhaps not even
spacex yeah perhaps
just the alarm
yeah because if if elon went away and
spacex went public and got a board of
directors i
there are more profitable things they
could be doing than focusing on human
presence on mars so this really is a
sort of personal thing there
and in contrast with that self-driving
cars have a dozen credible companies
working really hard
and while
yes it's going slower than most people
thought it would
betting against that is a bet against
almost the entire world in terms of all
of these companies that have all of
these incentives it's not just
you know one guy's passion project i've
and i do think that it is solvable i
although there's i recognize it's not
100 chance because it's possible the
long tail of self-driving problems winds
up being an agi complete problem
i think there's plenty of value to mine
out of it with narrow ai and i think
that it's you know it's going to happen
probably more so than people expect but
it's that whole sigmoid curve where you
over you know you overestimate the
near-term progress and you underestimate
the long-term progress and i think
self-driving is going to be like that
and i think 2030 is still a pretty good
bet
yeah unfortunately
um self-driving is a problem that uh
is safety critical meaning that
if if you don't do it well people get
hurt
but the other side of that is people are
terrible drivers so
it is not going to be that's probably
going to be the argument that gets it
through is like we can save 10 000 lives
a year by taking imperfect self-driving
cars and letting them take over a lot of
driving responsibilities it's like was
it 30 000 people a year die in auto
accidents right now in america and a lot
of those are preventable and the problem
is you'll have people that every time a
tesla crashes into something you've got
a bunch of people that literally have
vested interest shorting tesla to come
out and make it the worst thing in the
world and people will be fighting
against that but optimist in me again i
think that we will have systems that are
statistically safer than human drivers
and we will be saving
thousands and thousands of lives every
year when we can hand over more of those
responsibilities to it i do still think
as a person who studied this problem
very
deeply from a human side as well
it's still an open problem how good
slash bad humans are driving
it's a kind of
funny thing we say about each other oh
humans suck at driving
um
everybody except
you of course like we think we're good
at driving
but i
after really studying it i i think you
start to notice
you know because i've watched uh
hundreds of hours of humans driving with
the projects of this kind of thing
you've noticed that
even with the distraction even with
everything else
humans are able to
to do some incredible things
with the the with the attention even
when you're just looking at the
smartphone just to get cues from the
environment to make less seconds
decisions to use instinctual type of
decisions that actually save your ass
time and time and time again
and
are able to do that with so much
uncertainty around you in such tricky
dynamic environments i don't know i
don't i don't know exactly um
how hard is it to beat
that kind of
skill of common sense reasoning this is
one of those interesting things that
there have been a lot of studies about
how experts in their field usually
underestimate the progress that's going
to happen because an expert thinks about
all the problems they deal with and
they're like damn i'm going to have a
hard time solving all of this and they
filter out the fact that they are one
expert in a field of thousands and you
know you think about yeah i can't do all
of that and you sometimes forget about
the scope of the the ecosystem that
you're embedded in and if you think back
eight years very specifically the state
of ai and machine learning where it was
that we we had just gotten resnets
probably at that point and you look at
all the amazing magical things that have
happened in eight years and they do kind
of seem to be happening a little faster
in recent years also and you project
that eight more years into the future
where again i think there's a 50 chance
we're going to have signs of life of agi
you know which we can put through
driver's ed if we need to to actually
build self-driving cars and i think that
the narrow systems are going to to have
real value demonstrated well before then
you